You can also imagine a case where at first glance,
our results might suggest that there's no significant difference but it
turns out that there is. For example, say a website was
running an AB test between two different versions of our landing
page. They're trying to see which version of the page converts
more visits to clicks. Say they run a test for weeks
and weeks, placing 500,000 visitors into each test group. One strategy
had a conversion rate of 50%, another had a conversion rate
of 50.5%. If we run a significance test on this data, we can say with a
95% confidence level that there is a statistically
significant, albeit small difference between the two strategies.